what percent of you
when you're looking up at the stars and
wondering about this stuff thinks that
past parmia has is what happened on mars
or or on Earth
which is the building blocks of life
came from elsewhere well but you know
that's the thing
I think they're potential Vector which
means that you really distribute
stuff of life left and right but it
doesn't explain the origin of life it
does it's not the environment itself it
just promotes maybe and we still have to
prove this but what we know is that the
stuff we are made of is very abundant
all over the place including in
interstellar medium so it's all over
it's all over the idea is that maybe it
just waits to have the proper
environment and we know what it needs
here on Earth it needs water it needs
energy shelter and nutrient so you're
fundamentally interested in the origin
of life
and the big leaps
that in evolutionary history that could
be like an origin of something origin of
eucharia's origin of photosynthesis
origin of whatever I just think if we're
a civilization here on Earth and we
survive another few hundred years
I think it would be a good idea to take
a big gun and just shoot life out there
like a lifegun basically try to create
panspermia that's a good backup solution
so one way is to actually uh copy our
brains and actual humans some complex
information and send it out there
another way to preserve life is just to
like send the basic building blocks send
a bunch of bacteria a bunch of
whatever the rugged organisms are on
earth just send a bunch of those these
are not the building blocks they are
actual organisms so what is that a nice
shortcut or or do we want to because you
said building blocks are everywhere yeah
yeah bricks of Life the carbon hydrogen
Etc uh they they wear uh produced by the
death of precious Stars so this is how
they were produced and um stars like
arson uh started to form 10 billion
years ago that doesn't mean that the the
sun is the only kind of star that
produce you know life or an evil life
but actually was produced in uh 10
billion years ago now what you're
talking about is is a little different
right now there are many
um
many efforts to do the type of thing you
are talking about which is to put our
DNA on whatever kind of substrate and
preserve it in vaults either in
different place on Earth or on the moon
some people are already thinking about
putting DNA on the moon as far as brains
concerned and it's drawing towards
transhumanism which is uh the
enhancement of who we are through Ai and
machine learning of course having
backups is a good thing for me
I would say that taking care of our
planets and going back to a place where
we are in equilibrium with our
environment would be also maybe the best
backup possible
and let Evolution do its things right
now we are like teenagers with enough
brain to create Cool Tools
but we don't have enough brain to
understand yet the consequences of what
we are doing and right now we are paying
for this so uh the question is whether
we are going to be able to move
forward and learn from the mistakes we
are making to become a mature
civilization
you probably heard of the Drake equation
that would be the L at the very end the
duration the duration of intelligent
civilization exactly and and or at least
uh the length of time a civilization
remains detectable it can disappear from
the radar screen literally for a number
of reasons the first one is
destroy itself or being destroyed by
external uh events or it can become so
in tune
and with the universe and so Advanced
that it disappears because it melts
really in the background and it's not
visible anymore uh there are some wild
theories out there saying that and
civilization might be so Advanced that
you cannot distinguish them from
physical processes and uh that was an
example doesn't say that this is the
case but some people say imagine that in
fact all the dark matter that we we see
or we we theorized about is in fact some
sort of a biological uh process so you
can think about a number of things
personally I believe that
what you talk about about preserving our
information is kind of what life does we
we need to look at ourselves uh as not
different
of what the little cell that started off
was and this is what tells you not about
the origin of life but in fact the
nature of life which is a lot more
interesting to me because it is the
nature of life is really what is going
to give you some Universal signature to
look for it all over the place and not
only around ponds of water for Life as
we know it but the nature of life is
telling you that life wants to
get the most information possible around
its surroundings and complexities in
fact the ability to
gather and exchange and preserve the
most information possible and and so
what you're saying is kind of preserving
the kind of information we have